en el vídeo anterior construimos un
escenario en donde se mostraban los
beneficios de una inversión y las
pérdidas estaban limitadas a un 15 por
ciento de nuestra inversión en este caso
era el 25.5 y bueno creo que tuve por
ahí un error de matemáticas estaba yo
escribiendo 24 con 50 en lugar de 25.50
pero yo espero que a pesar de eso no
hayan tenido problema en entender la
esencia del vídeo y para revisar lo que
hicimos 30 dólares vale el bien que
queremos comprar pero en lugar de ir y
comprar directamente este bien por 30
dólares lo que hicimos fue poner a un
lado 25 50 y usamos los 450 para
participar en el proyecto o plan de
geithner nosotros pusimos 450
el tesoro también pone 450 mil
y la reserva federal- nos presta
51 dólares y con esto pudimos comprar 60
dólares en bienes o el doble de lo que
originalmente queríamos invertir y lo
hicimos así porque estamos repartiendo
nos en partes iguales el beneficio de
esta inversión en el vídeo anterior
vimos como luce la gráfica de ganancias
y vamos a volver a dibujar aquí y espero
que esta sea una versión un poquito más
limpia comparada con la versión del
vídeo anterior ese será el valor
eventual del título y el eje vertical
será el valor eventual de mi inversión
si yo fuera invertir directamente a este
título el valor de mi título o el valor
de mi inversión sería el valor del
título por lo que luce algo así si el
valor del título resulta que es de 30
dólares entonces el valor de mi
inversión será de 30 dólares ese es el
escenario en donde yo directamente hago
la compra de este título si este título
termina valiendo nada pues perderé toda
mi inversión si el título resulta que
vale 60 dólares mi inversión también
valdrá 60 dólares
no hay nada complicado aquí lo que vimos
en el vídeo anterior es que si nosotros
tenemos este escenario en donde ponemos
a un lado 25 50 y solo tenemos 450 en
riesgo en este tipo de realidad lo que
tenemos es si el valor de nuestro título
resulta ser menor que 25 50 los dueños
del equilibrio se quedan con nada así
que aquí mil 450 terminarán valiendo
nada y aunque estos 450 ya los perdí aún
conservo mis 25 50 que hice a un lado al
principio pérdidas están limitadas a
solamente 4 dólares con 50 centavos que
es el capital que tengo en riesgo así
que el diagrama de ganancias
ahora luce así en el escenario positivo
con mi inversión de 450 recibo todos los
beneficios que obtendría normalmente
pero en el lado pesimista lo más que
puedo llegar a perder son 450 no más no
importa qué es lo que suceda con este
título al menos me voy a quedar con 25
50 así
en el peor de los casos es que yo
pierdan estos 450 que invertir
suponiendo que el precio original que
pague es de 30 dólares para este título
aquí estaría mi pérdida y aquí estaría
mi ganancia ahora veamos si podemos
construir en caso de que no existiera el
plan de geithner una situación que se
comporte de manera similar a esto
recibir la misma ganancia pero usando
títulos un poquito más convencionales y
de poder hacer esto podríamos ponerle un
precio a estos títulos más
convencionales y después tener un mejor
entendimiento del subsidio que está
dando el gobierno así que en lugar del
plan de geithner digamos que nosotros
tenemos una inversión directa en este
título 30 dólares
y también adquirimos un contrato de
seguridad o de seguro de manera que
compramos el título por 30 dólares y
también compramos una opción de venta y
esto suena sofisticado pero lo que
realmente es
es un contrato de seguro sobre un título
de manera que compramos una opción de
venta y esto nos va a dar el derecho va
a ser un contrato que dice que nosotros
podemos vender tenemos el derecho a
vender nuestro título por 25 50 y no es
obligatorio tener que vender nuestro
título por 25 50 digamos que el título
terminó valiendo 60 dólares entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es tomar nuestro
contrato de opción de venta y romperlo
ya que no queremos ejercerlo no vamos a
vender esto que vale 60 dólares por 25
50 finalmente no necesitamos este seguro
pero imaginemos que nos encontramos de
este otro lado que es lo que compramos
esté bien tóxico realmente no vale nada
y bueno aquí tenemos este contrato en el
que me puse de acuerdo con alguien más
que está
de acuerdo en comprarme ese título por
25 50 tenemos la opción de venta de 25
50 y eso es solamente para que conozcan
un poco de los términos técnicos
relacionados con esto aunque yo creo que
muchos de ustedes ya están
familiarizados con estos términos este
es el precio del ejercicio de nuestra
opción de venta y ahora cómo se vería
nuestro diagrama de ganancias pues ya
que tengo este seguro todos estos
escenarios en donde mi título vale más
que 25 50 mi ganancia se verá así y en
los escenarios pesimistas cuál va a ser
mi ganancia o mi pago si el título
resulta que vale un poco menos de 25 50
si yo me encuentro aquí y el mercado
indica que solo va a pagar 12 dólares
por este título pero yo tengo este
contrato de seguro donde esta otra
persona está dispuesta a pagarme a 25 50
por este título así que en cualquiera de
estos otros escenarios pues yo voy a
ejercer esta opción de venta y lo
venderé a 25 o 50 así que en todos estos
casos pesimistas yo aun recibiré mis 25
50 por esta opción de venta que compre
así que como ven este diagrama de
ganancias es idéntico al que nos da el
gobierno así que durante toda esta
estructura esta asociación
público-privada lo que en esencia está
haciendo el gobierno es dándonos una
opción de venta con un precio del
ejercicio de 25 50 y para encontrar qué
tan grande es este subsidio pues tenemos
que encontrar cuál es la opción de venta
que tiene un precio del ejercicio de 25
50 y déjenme decirles que esto no es
realmente nada fácil de calcular ya que
se tiene que saber sobre la volatilidad
del título
sus dividendos y de hecho las personas
que descubrieron los cálculos para
encontrar esto ganaron premios nobeles
sin embargo es un problema conocido y lo
que voy a hacer aquí aunque esto es un
poco teórico lo que la gente hace en
realidad es ver lo que el mercado está
ofreciendo de opciones de venta y tratar
de descubrir cuáles son las suposiciones
implicadas
de hecho la volatilidad es la suposición
más grande yo busqué un poco en internet
y me encontré con esta página más punto
columbia punto edu diagonal tilde
smirnoff diagonal options 13 puntos html
y esto es una calculadora de opciones y
bueno voy a arriesgarme a usar esto que
fue hecho por seguramente un estudiante
de doctorado o profesor de columbia que
sabe cómo calcular opciones y los
resultados tienen sentido este es el
título en nuestro caso es de 30 dólares
el precio del ejercicio es de 25 50 la
tasa de interés está es una tasa de
interés libre de riesgo aunque también
podría ser el interés de la deuda pero
digamos
en este caso es algo pequeño la tasa de
interés es baja en este momento digamos
que es del 2% el rendimiento de los
dividendos bueno cuando compramos estos
títulos tóxicos cuando compramos estos
bienes tóxicos tienen un rendimiento
bastante grande y si se compran a 30
centavos de dólar el rendimiento estará
en el rango del 30 por ciento más o
menos y si jugamos con esas suposiciones
y aquí yo estoy tratando de ser lo más
favorable posible para ver qué tan
grande podría ser este subsidio en
realidad aunque ustedes pueden jugar con
estos parámetros en su tiempo libre
volatilidad por año pues yo creo que el
30 por ciento es bastante justo en
cualquier año el valor percibido de esto
podría fluctuar un 30% y la fecha de
expiración estos son bienes de larga
duración muchos bienes de hipotecas
tienen una madurez de 10 años así que en
lugar de 365 días pues pongamos 3600 50
días 10 años y calculamos lo aquí lo que
nos interesa es la opción de venta
americana aunque en futuros vídeos
veremos la diferencia entre la opción
europea y la opción americana el opción
americana quiere decir que se puede
ejercer en cualquier momento que uno
desee mientras que la opción europea hay
una fecha para ejercer esto y es el
único momento en el que se puede ejercer
pero la opción americana dice que el
valor de esto para las suposiciones que
indicamos es de 19 dólares con 50
centavos lo cual es un subsidio bastante
grande y bueno es cierto que los números
cambian conforme pasa el tiempo si
hacemos más pequeño el rendimiento del
título y lo re calculamos nos da algo
más pequeño pero no importa qué tanto
juguemos con estas suposiciones así que
lo que nos dice esta calculadora de
opciones es que el precio correcto
teórico para una opción de venta para un
título con esas características 30% de
volatilidad y un rendimiento del 30% ya
que está pagando muchos dividendos ya
que las personas están pagando sus
cuotas de hipoteca entonces el valor de
la opción de venta que se podría comprar
en el mercado va de 15 a 20 dólares por
lo que una inversionista racional que
pague de 15 a 20 dólares por esta opción
de venta cuando estará dispuesto a pagar
por el título
este seguro digamos que este
inversionista racional está dispuesto a
pagar 30 dólares por el título como lo
mencionamos antes y además tiene que
comprar la opción de venta y tiene que
pagar de 15 a 20 dólares por esta así
que en teoría esos inversionistas
estarían dispuestos a pagar 30 dólares
más el valor de la opción de venta que
va de 45 a 50 dólares en total y ahora
quiero que esto quede muy claro si el
inversionista con esta opción
digamos que termina pagando 50 dólares
quien se va a beneficiar de esto si el
inversionista privado termina pagando 50
dólares ya que esencialmente el gobierno
está ofreciendo una opción de venta
gratuita si se pagan 50 dólares de hecho
se está pagando por lo que el gobierno
está ofreciendo están pagando por la
opción así que el beneficiario real es
la persona que vende el bien tóxico que
son estos bancos que seguramente no son
solventes así que el subsidio no va a ir
al inversionista privado va a ir a los
bancos si lo que está dispuesto a pagar
el inversionista que son 30 dólares
fuera al mismo precio de lo que está
dispuesto a los bancos a vender sus
bienes
sólo así el subsidio beneficiaría al
inversionista privado el punto de este
ejercicio es que si el mercado actual
dice que las personas están dispuestas a
pagar sólo 30 dólares por esto
y los bancos no están dispuestos a
vender esto por menos de 60 dólares ya
que si no lo hicieran se irían a
bancarrota aún cuando está esta opción
que está dando el gobierno y aún si
hubieran inversionistas que estén
dispuestos a pagar todo esto incluyendo
el precio de la opción de venta
encontramos que lo máximo que estarían
dispuestos a pagar son 45 o 50 dólares y
así los inversionistas privados
realmente no tienen alguna ganancia o
valor extra de todo este proceso por lo
tanto pues no va a elegir esta opción lo
que nos lleva al segundo vídeo del plan
geithner aún cuando existen estas
opciones y una inversionista racional
sólo está dispuesto a pagar máximo 45 50
dólares como podría funcionar este plan
ya vimos que uno no funcionaría en
absoluto ya que a pesar de esto el
inversionista privado ocasional no está
dispuesto a pagar lo que pide el banco o
si se implementa pues va a ocurrir lo
que describí en el segundo vídeo en
donde los bancos tienen este enorme
incentivo de comprar esto a ellos mismos
y crea
estos fondos de cobertura protegidos y a
lo mejor hago algunos vídeos sobre todas
las formas en la que los bancos pueden
hacer esto y créanme que los bancos son
expertos en hacer este tipo de cosas
organizaciones que ellos pueden
controlar y que pueden participar en
estos planes del gobierno para al final
comprar los bienes de ellos mismos así
que en mi opinión cuando veamos que este
programa comienza a llevarse a cabo si
vemos que se están comprando estos
bienes por 70 centavos de dólar o 80
centavos de dólar estas peticiones de
compras seguramente vienen de los mismos
bancos ya que no hay algo racional
incluyendo con la opción de venta para
que un inversionista regular participe
en esto y aquí hay un argumento de
liquidez detenida y es un argumento que
está dando el plan de geithner de que no
sólo se trata de estos subsidios también
se está dando poder de compra ya que
ahora están todos estos vendedores
angustiados y no hay tantos compradores
y apalancando un poco las cosas se
incrementa el el poder de compra y en el
siguiente vídeo analizaremos que si ese
es el verdadero problema que quiere
resolver el plan d
hay una mucho mejor manera de resolverlo
que esta asociación público-privada que
esencialmente permite a los bancos
establecer sus propios precios y si se
permite a los bancos establecer el
precio se hará una transferencia de
riquezas directamente del dinero de los
impuestos hacia los bancos que
cometieron los errores o se da una
opción de venta que es una opción
valiosa para varios fondos de cobertura
que quizás podrían estar interesados en
participar y es mucho más válido hacer
esto que transferir dinero de los
contribuyentes a los bancos eso lo
veremos en el siguiente vídeo y espero
que este vídeo les haya permitido tener
un mejor entendimiento de lo que está
haciendo el gobierno y como ustedes
pueden evaluar lo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo